and uh let's get into that that first
big story this one I think is actually
very amazing from timcast.com Joe Rogan
sold out Vancouver show canceled due to
vaccine mandates quote I don't even
think I can get into the country Rogan
said comedian podcast host Joe Rogan
said it sold out April show in Canada is
unlikely to it to take place because of
the vaccine mandates now I'll tell you
something when I first saw this clip
from Joe on his show where he was like I
don't think we can do the show
I was immediately like whoa whoa is
anybody writing up is there other more
details on this so I sent it to our
Newsroom which is supported by members
at timcast.com and I was like can you
guys look into this pull it up and they
write this story Joe Rogan sold out
Vancouver show canceled I immediately
was like whoa whoa guys guys he didn't
cancel the show he's saying he might
cancel and they were like no no Tim
don't worry we fact checked it it's true
from ticketmaster.ca event canceled
unfortunately the event organizer has
had to cancel your event no action or
required to obtain a refund it will be
processed to the original method of
payment yada they go on and that's it
Joe Rogan goes on his show says he
doesn't think he can do the show and
then we get confirmation from
Ticketmaster the Show is canceled good
on Joe Rogan
good for him I don't know if he actually
canceled the shot of principle it may
just be function like he literally can't
get into Canada so you can't have the
show but I think people need to start
realizing this I was having a
conversation with some friends and
family if you keep enabling these
lunatics they will keep pushing until
you say no and make them understand
there will be consequences for this so
This Stadium this city you're going to
lose all of that money from one of the
most famous comedians in the world yeah
I don't know if Joe had a choice here
because Canada is not allowing anyone
who's not vaccinated into their country
so there's a lot of other people like
Jim Brewer who had to cancel their shows
because they clearly just weren't
allowed to be in Canada at all and that
is absolutely ridiculous Joe Rogan has
antibodies he went through coronavirus
he he got on the other side he of course
used Alternatives he didn't take the
vaccine but but he clearly has you know
antibodies within him that that prevent
him from from getting sick from the
basic understanding of it isn't isn't
this the goal of the vaccine right this
someone said this to me they were like
the goal of the vaccine is to trigger an
immune response in your body so it
produces antibodies right yeah so if you
have the antibodies it's effective like
what's the difference well it clearly
has something to do more with just
protecting People's Health and there's
something larger play I'm not pretending
to know what that is but the thing we
need to look at now is not why he
canceled it but the fact that it got
canceled and suppliers need to cut off
companies or countries or venues that
literally take away people's personal
freedom to make a choice on whether they
want to take this medical procedure or
not that's the key by Joe Rogan doing
this it sends a message directly to
their pocketbooks directly to their
ability to generate income and at the
end of the day money is what solves this
and that's how we solve this is we cut
off the supply
I think a lot of people will think about
this in the sense like Joe Rogan's Rich
right so they're like okay he's
canceling the show how how much will
this one show impact the bottom you know
his bottom line but I think the bigger
thing is
there's probably I mean I think it's
fair to say tons of smaller shows that
got canceled and wiped out we we learn
all about the small businesses that were
shut down in the lockdowns now with
vaccine mandates we've seen all of these
reports from various cities about how
their business drops by like 30 percent
what you're not going to hear in the
news is Small Time comedian who packs
you know maybe 50 people into a room
unlike Joe Rogan who sells out a stadium
you get one small comedian who travels
around doing these comedy shows opening
acts and his career is done yeah there's
no more income there's no more show and
it's whether they want to do it or not
but like I was just saying
there needs to be consequences the
problem is if this stuff keeps happening
then our culture is being ripped apart
no comedy show from Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan's literally the guy who goes up
there and Rags on all this stuff so if
he's not doing this then people aren't
hearing it they're getting their
opinions filtered through social media
it's a tricky problem man I think
there's probably a lot of people
involved with these shows because you
need to understand people need to
understand this is not just like Joe
shows up and a show happens I mean
you've got crew you've got vendors
you've got marketing companies you've
got the stadium you've got insurance
this is probably going to be Millions
upon Millions maybe maybe seven or eight
figures in terms of Revenue going into
this now gone yeah and it's a government
and this yeah all nonsensical
non-scientific policies even the UK
government did a study saying vaccine
mandates don't actually help anything
here they do promote people to get the
vaccine which is uh they're all end-all
belief system here but but as we know
here the data is still very early
there's still a lot of conflicted
information we don't know exactly what's
going on here but but to close off from
business to close off from individuals
to restrict people's ability to travel
based on this notion that we still
haven't figured out that we still don't
know the consequences of is ridiculous
this is this is the this is the problem
of people complying this is the problem
of all these experts these Democrats are
otherwise who are telling everybody you
have to abide by these restrictions but
then are caught not abiding by them
which clearly shows you want to call my
hypocrite fine but these you know
Gretchen Whitmer is it a bar Gavin
newsom's at a restaurant Nancy Pelosi is
getting her hair done they're not scared
at all whatever it is they do whatever
it is they know they're not scared of
this now I'm not I don't know but if
your attitude is I'm gonna pass all
these rules and then we're going to
ignore them you're sending a huge
message to people not to take this
seriously but are people listening to
the message you still got it appears to
be a large percentage of population who
listen to falsi who listen to Pelosi who
listen to Biden who clearly looked down
on them as peasants and do exactly the
opposite of what they tell us to do so
the question is where are these people
when are these people going to wake up
when are they going to be like hey how
come Biden's walking around and the
servers are one way and he's the other
way when they can't get their pizza when
they can't go to their comedy show when
they're when they're now being
confronted uh like in Chicago they're
doing the vaccine mandate on the third I
talked to a lot of people in Chicago who
are like all of a sudden hey man what's
this you know I did everything I was
told at everything right now they're
going to do more mandates well that's
right did you think you could comply
your way out of tyranny well it goes
from from the actual like shots went
from okay you get two and you're done
now it's like nah you need three Israel
I think did four right they're already
implementing for the fourth Israel is
going to be up to 10 by the end of the
year and it's the freaking 27th what was
that what was that ad there was like a
billboard that was going viral I haven't
fact checked this but it's like an ad
that says your coveted vaccine is like a
battery it needs to be recharged so it
was only the United Kingdom
um that released it and it literally
said you got to take the booster to make
sure you have immunity but that destroys
the definition of vaccine that's not a
vaccine well well hold on tons of
vaccines have boosters like when I got
yellow fever I had to get I had to get a
booster after six months but so quickly
I mean we're talking about how long how
long do you have to get a booster
with the with the other one yellow fever
okay that I was wrong on that one yeah
I'm like look I think the bigger issue
is policy it's that they promised us
people abided by this and then the terms
change it's literally Darth Vader being
like the terms of the deal have changed
probably I don't alter them further it's
like at this point you're going to I
know you're going to so now people are
losing all Faith they're losing faith in
any look it's it's almost annoying to
even bring up because we've all lost
faith in this yeah Joe Biden coming out
and being like you need to get
vaccinated now because there's a winter
of death and suffering and I'm like bro
your words are meaningless to me
completely meaningless you can say it
over and over again every single person
can come out and say the exact same
thing yo we're well beyond the point
where those words have any meaning yeah
and it's and what's happening now the
point that I should have made here is
that it's the exact opposite of what
they promised it would be they never
said from the beginning hey this is
going to be temporary it's going to wane
you're going to need to do this every
couple months they never said that they
said one and done that's it you're fine
here just take this everything will go
back to normal it clearly hasn't it
clearly hasn't worked a lot of people
that I talk to I talk to a lot of people
in New York City over the last few days
they're they're disenfranchised they're
they're confused they're like they don't
know what to believe anymore but I think
the sentiment nationally is that people
are kind of sick of it they're they're
sick of the fear-mongering and and they
have been essentially told almost every
single day they're gonna die they're
gonna die unless they comply and a lot
of them have been complying but we're
reaching a point where a lot of them are
like looking around being like what's
the point like why shut up I'm I'm I'm
completely burned out on all of this
stuff I got covered it was the worst
sickness I ever got I say that a lot it
was it was bad I I gen genuinely thought
I was like about to go to the hospital
and then I got the monoclonal antibodies
and all that stuff I actually had
medical intervention on this it's bad
but I want to live I want to you know
out here where we are we go to the
movies it's totally fine I was in
Chicago and they have a city-wide mask
mandate and half the people aren't even
abiding by it not a single person ever
told me I had to wear a mask or whatever
it just doesn't make sense I walk into a
restaurant and I'm like do I really got
to put this on for literally five
seconds because my table is right there
and then you sit down and take it off
I'm like what are what are we doing with
this like I understand if you want to
say there should be a mask man it slows
the spread well then everyone should be
wearing them their masks the entire time
they're in the building but they're not
doing it no one's doing it it's not
being taken seriously now they're
they're they're like okay we're gonna do
a vaccine mandate for the city then then
then what's gonna happen people aren't
going to abide by it well we're just
good I guess we never did it right like
there are specific protocols for how you
use masks you touch it you throw it away
yeah once you touch it it's gone if they
were serious if this was serious if
masks they might say Max work if math
actual masks actually did what they were
supposed to do there's a really great
video showing they do what they're
supposed to do the problem is like even
fauci has brought this up it very early
on he's like you touch it you're you're
getting you know what did he say you're
getting shorts on it and stuff it's like
you said
it's really simple to come out and say
masks work well of course doctors wear
them for a reason the problem is a bunch
of people look I was walking through
Chicago every mask was under their nose
and no one says a word and I'm like
what's the point if you're not going to
actually tell people to fix it if you if
you don't care nobody cared I guess my
point is everybody's just burned out on
this I'm so burned out I'm so sick and
tired of talking about it two years man
well we're not wearing the proper masks
if we actually had n95s fitted and if
you touch it you throw it away you wash
your hands and scrub them and surgeons
are wearing them for different reasons
in the hospital setting they only wore
them during surgery I never had a doctor
come out to me at a hospital I spent a
lot of time in the hospital as a kid
because my mom would be in and out of
hospitals my dad was really sick never
once the doctor come out with a mask
that wasn't a thing they put it on to
prevent getting splattered in the face
by some projectile kidney fluid or or
the other with them spitting or for them
but but to prevent life to actually walk
around and think this is going to stop
something microscopic and n95s do but
you have to fit them right no no I I
this is we had this argument before with
somebody because Steve was it Steve yeah
uh uh you can get coveted through spit
and through aerosolized you know water
Vapors yeah so the masks stopped the
spin well they stopped the spit but they
they're still stuff going through them
it does reduce the viral load I will
admit it's a spit and if there's viruses
in the spit so my thing is just
basically my point is this not MediCal I
I really could I really don't care to
have medical arguments about dying and
Doffing or whatever I think you make a
good point about proper way it's called
donning and Doffing right yes when
you're how you're supposed to put it on
how you supposed to take it off it's
just people like literally with these
nasty unclean masks my thing is just if
nobody cares anymore if people in
Chicago aren't abiding buy it and
they're like we're gonna up the mandates
I just don't see how this just just it's
over like the the policies people are
fed up in Chicago I'm getting I'm
hearing people complain about this
saying I can't believe how insane it's
getting I'm not going to do this and I'm
hearing people saying they're going to
leave and then we look at there's
there's this graph that's been going
around on Twitter showing California New
York Illinois largest population Exodus
in the Country Florida and Texas major
boom in population people are voting
with their feet they're saying I don't
care I'm done I'm out well they're
they're voting and they're moving away
from from government because government
almost every step of the way here made
the situation that much worse for masks
Dr fauci and and the CDC were telling
people from the very beginning you don't
need masks then you need masks then you
need two masks then you don't need two
mats again the messaging was always
confusing we never prioritized early
treatment we never talked about building
up the terrain fighting obesity helping
people's immune systems we never talked
about a lot of the issues that could
have according to some medical
professionals really made an impact here
it was always one procedure one product
the vaccine always we need to do that
and that that to me was was just uh a
misnomer and a lot of people are asking
serious questions about that specific
stance last year
I can't remember exactly when it was but
I was listening to Joe Rogan's show and
he started he was talking about covid
again and I was like we're all locked
down it's hard to fly people and get
guests we were we didn't even have
guests until like August of last year
when restrictions started to ease and
I'll just listen to the show and I was
like
you know
Joe is the best one of the biggest and
best podcasts in the world and even he
is just talking about covet over and
over again and I'm like are we seriously
now it's been two years and I can't tell
you how much of the content we've done
is literally just covered
yeah it's just crazy to me that we're
still in this Matrix world of this is
life this is life it's all it is all the
news all the big stories is just how bad
are things getting now and I'm like
last week you know I'm like hey Luke
before the show like what's the big
stories and Luke's like we got this on
kova these protests and I'm like yo I
don't care I was like I can't talk about
this stuff let's talk about something
else yeah now now we're we're you know
what ended up happening is
DC Baltimore Philly I'm not sorry not
Baltimore uh Boston Philly Chicago they
all announced these these mandates
right before Christmas when no one's
paying attention when no one knows
exactly what's going on and I got them
talking to people and they're like wait
what's happening and I'm like you didn't
hear us Chicago is going to require you
to get a vaccine they're like I didn't I
didn't know I'm like yeah because people
are with their families and so all this
news dumps the same time everybody wants
to have a good time and they want to
think about fun family stuff and here we
are once again it's been two years who I
I can't remember who this was they said
zooby I think it was he said my vocal my
vocabulary around covet is officially
gone I'm not going to talk about it ever
again I don't care anymore and I'm like
I feel I think it was Ubi maybe I'm just
like I feel you man
I'm burned out on this so much nothing's
changed I mean things keep changing but
they say the same you know in a certain
way in that 15 days to slow the spread
becomes three months becomes where a
mass becomes wear two mask I get it by
next year we'll all be wearing gigantic
plastic bubble suits and we'll be in our
10th booster shot is that where we're
going look I'm just gonna go I'm gonna
take care of the chickens I'm gonna
skate we've got we we have a bottle of
trump champagne we're gonna be cracking
open on New Year's and I'm gonna live my
life so Tim here's a question back to
the masks real quick when do we get to
take them off like okay we know they do
so okay let's say they work when do we
get to let our kids see each other's
facial expressions wait wait what do you
mean take them off no no no no no no you
gotta put more on Dr fauci
Dr fauci today said came out he said
don't even consider removing your masks
when you're on the flight yeah that
guy's nuts at the end of the day you
know you have a situation where there's
always going to be some stuff floating
around in the air there's always going
to be something dude I was taken down
for five days by hand foot and mouth
disease he's from going to a children's
museum I couldn't walk my hands
literally sloft off I had no fingernails
and I wasn't like man I wish I wore a
mask and I was like oh shoot I got a
virus maybe I should take better care of
my health or maybe I should look into
what vitamins prevent viruses instead of
like oh let me cover my face and force
my kids to cover their face and fly with
a facial coverage that's absurd that's
insane you know I was thinking I was
like
we could mandate a whole lot of things
to keep people safe I made this joke on
Twitter I was like let's mandate morning
calisthenics I think that's great I'm
down for the elephant
I'll do jumping jacks I don't care get
rid of fast food uh you know let's get
rid of a Monsanto gotta keep Chipotle in
there I don't know about that I don't
know he's good it's got chicken rice
I am taking offense he's an anti-body
build I
don't know yes I think I think I think
you know why I love going to Chipotle
because they've got you your meal is
going to be fats and proteins yes I I
don't I don't do the rice and the beans
oh I do the hell out of rice man I'll do
a whole lot of drugs in this body come
on I will I will get the the peppers and
onions the chicken and then I'll be like
cheese guacamole sour cream perfect you
can make your perfect meal if you have a
low-fat high protein diet you could have
a high fat um high protein diet you
could have what you could have a vegan
diet like I'm sorry Chipotle Moe's Qdoba
if you're looking for fast food that can
actually fit whatever diet you're on I'm
simping for those guys man that's some
good that's some good eating thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time